in this video I want to talk about the
tryptophan operon in prokaryotes the
tryptophan operon is a repressible
operon repressible system repressible
means you can turn it off so normally
it's on and it can be turned off or
repressed so what is this tryptophan
operon involved in well tryptophan is an
amino acid and this operon is involved
in making these structural genes that
are involved in making tryptophan so
they make the amino acid now normally
it's on ok but now that the regulatory
gene of the tryptophan operon here
represented by R or for repressible
makes its mrna and then RNA is
transcribed into mRNA and then is
translated into the protein that protein
is the tryptophan repressor now if the
system is normally on well this
repressor normally be bound well no
right because a repressor would stop it
or turn it off but that's not normally
what happens normally it's on
so this repressor is inactive by default
or normally inactive so normally this
operon just goes ahead and makes
tryptophan now once there once the
tryptophan is made tryptophan can bind
the repressor and then the repressor can
bind the operator so it looks something
like this now when this trip defend
available it can bind the repressor and
then the repressor can go over and once
the tryptophan is bound then the
repressor protein can bind and then
block Trent transcription of these
structural genes so in this case
tryptophan acts as a co-repressor it
helps the repressor go because the
repressor is inactive by default in
order to activate it
tryptophan needs to be balanced so in
this case now we have the active
tryptophan repressor when it has
tryptophan bound so in this case
the structural genes are not transcribed
so then tryptophan cannot be made does
that make sense well yeah because
tryptophan is clearly available it's
available here you don't need to make
more if you already have it so let's
think about this here so if we have if
there's tryptophan if there's no
tryptophan available what happens that
means we want to make more or make some
so no tryptophan available makes them so
does that mean the operon will be on or
off
well this up this operon is involved in
making them so it'll be on so will the
repressor be bound if the operon is
supposed to be making some nope then
we'll not because then it repressor is
there the in transcription cannot occur
what if tryptophan is available then you
want to stop making tryptophan and we
want to stop making tryptophan would you
want the operator to be on or off
you want it to be off so will the
repressor rebound yep it will be bound
and it needs tryptophan to be a co
repressor so essentially the amount of
tryptophan regulates the tryptophan
production if tryptophan is available
tryptophan stops the production of
itself if there's no tryptophan
available then the repressor is not
bound and tryptophan can be made so this
process the idea that tryptophan
regulates its own production is called
Auto regulation it regulates the amount
of production of itself so it's sort of
like a sort of like a negative feedback
right the idea that
there's if there's tryptophan around we
stop making it if there's no tryptophan
around then we make it that's pretty
much the idea of the tryptophan operon I
hope that video was helpful in
understanding it one last thing I am a
tutor if you live in Southern California
feel free to contact me via email at
Luke University at gmail.com see the
description below for more details thank
you for watching